time management
yeah uh you know i think one of the most
imp
a great goal in life would be to not
have to be in a given place at a given
time uh that is a that is a recent
vector that i'm trying to work towards
uh obviously it's not fully realistic
you know you have meetings and stuff but
at a even more basic level you have a
job right most people most of us have
jobs we've got to go in a certain time
of the day and can't come back to a
certain time and
somebody else is telling us what to do
all day long uh and i think it's really
worth
whenever you can in life if you have the
choice optimizing for independence
rather than optimizing for pay because
if you have independence
and you're just accountable let's say on
your output as opposed to your input
that's the dream being accountable for
your output rather than your input
we're used to you know humans evolved in
societies where there was no leverage so
if i was chopping wood or carrying water
for you you knew that roughly eight
hours put in would be equal to about
eight hours of work that came out but
now we've been invented leverage through
capital through co-working through
technology through productivity you know
through all these means so we live in an
age of leverage and as a worker you want
to be as leveraged as possible so that
your work has a huge impact and it won't
take as much of your time
or physical effort like you'd rather
work with a bulldozer than uh work with
uh you know with your hands the same way
you'd rather work with a computer than
you would with a pencil so those are
just forms of leverage so you want to
use as much leverage as possible
and a leveraged worker can pre out
produce a non-leveraged worker by a
factor of a thousand or ten thousand and
with a leveraged worker the choice of uh
you know how they make the decision is
far more important uh their judgment is
far more important uh than how much time
they put in or how hard they worked so
for example a good software engineer
just by writing the right little piece
of code and creating the right little
application can literally create half a
billion dollars worth of value for a
company but
10 engineers working 10 times as hard
just because they chose the wrong model
or the right wrong product or wrote it
the wrong way
or that put in the wrong viral loop or
what have you
you know they basically wasted their
time so inputs don't
match outputs especially for leveraged
workers and so what you want to do in
life is you want to be in control of
your own time so you want to get into a
leveraged job and then you want to get
into one where you control your own time
and you're tracked on the outputs that
would be the ideal because then if you
do something incredible to move the
needle on the business they're going to
have to pay you and they're going to
have to pay you and especially if they
don't know how you did it because it's
innate to kind of your obsession or your
skill or your innate abilities then
they're going to have to keep paying you
to do it this goes back to what i talked
about in the first podcast
if you have specific knowledge you have
accountability and you have leverage
they have to pay you what you're worth
and if they pay you uh if they pay you
what you're worth uh then you can get
your time back and if you get your time
back then you can be hyper efficient
then you're not doing meetings for
meetings sake then you're not trying to
impress other people you're not building
checklists and writing down lots of
things just to kind of make it look like
you did work all you care about is the
actual work itself
and when you do just the actual work
itself you'll be
far more productive far more efficient
you'll work when you're kind of feel
like it when you're high energy and you
won't be trying to struggle through when
you're low energy and you'll regain your
time back
so i think choosing what kinds of jobs
and careers and fields you get into and
what sort of
you know deals you're willing to take
from your employer assuming you have
that luxury
will give you much more free time and
then you don't have to worry as much
about time management
you know
the the image that i like to put in my
own head what i would love to do is i
would love to be paid purely for my
judgment not for any work
you know i want the robots to do the
work
or you know capital or dollars being
deployed somewhere out there to do the
work
or computers to do the work but i want
to be paid for my judgment and i think
every human should aspire to that where
we're eventually just becoming
knowledgeable uh or we are knowledgeable
about certain things and we're being
paid for that unique thing
and we have as much leverage as possible
in that business whether it's through
robots or computers or what have you
and then we can also be masters of our
and of our own time because we're just
being tracked in outputs and not inputs
yeah think about ceos you know people
always complain about ceo pay they don't
understand how it works
um think about this uh if you're running
a public 100 billion dollar company
right like you're ceo of a real company
it's worth a hundred billion dollars
i'm sure you can find competent people
who do that job for half a million bucks
a year for a million bucks a year 2
million bucks a year but imagine someone
comes along who demonstrably has
slightly better judgment like you know
85 percent instead of 75 percent of the
time they're right well you will pay
that person
you know 50 million 100 million 200
million dollars whatever it takes
because that 10 better judgment is
steering a 100 billion dollar ship so
ceos are highly paid because of their
leverage so small
differences in judgment and capability
really get amplified look at
professional sports uh nobody wants to
watch you know the third place the
bronze medal winner everybody wants to
watch the gold medal winner so the gold
medal winner will get paid multiples
because their leverage their reach is to
millions of individuals whereas the
bronze medal winner has a reach to
hundreds or thousands of uh uh
of individuals um so they can just so
just for being a marginally better like
running that quarter mile and you know
fraction of a second faster they're
going to get paid a lot more orders of
magnitude more so leverage just has that
effect and magnifies things so being at
the extreme in your art uh
is very important in an age of leverage
and you're never going to be the best in
the world at anything unless it's
something that you just absolutely love
to do
no one can compete with you on being you
no one can compete with me on being me
so when i think about what my profession
what my job what my work is it's just
being me what am i doing on periscope
right now why am i here i'm just me
being me i don't have any other good
explanation for it but i just know no
one's going to beat me being me so if i
ever need to make money off of it i can
and i'm going to be darn good at it
[Music]
[Music]
you